ladies and gentlemen welcome to another
wild ride with stevo and what can i say
dude the streak just
keeps going one huge star
after another and what can we say about
this guy that we don't say on this
podcast
oh my god it's outrageous
ladies and gentlemen adam devine yeah
dude i like that
i want you to meet my co-host scott
randolph what's up
what's up scott how's it going man how's
it going up at the front of the rv we
have
paul briskey what's up adam how are you
what's up paul
great to talk to you so really nice you
have a a very
sultry sounding voice there oh my god i
appreciate that i don't know what's
sexier his voice or his face
i haven't seen his face so i'm gonna i'm
gonna take your word for it uh dude i
surround myself with hot guys adam yeah
lots of hot boys yeah dude so
ah man first off thank you for doing
this man i feel like we need a sample on
our little sound board for a [ __ ]
huge star alert
like hit people with the same [ __ ]
like when people ask me so what stunt
hurt the most and you know like
but uh i do find it interesting that as
i understand
it you came right out of youtube right
like just
yeah well yeah kind of me and the guys
we uh
from workaholics we started like just
doing youtube videos and [ __ ] i mean to
be perfectly honest
uh you guys inspired the whole jackass
crew inspired a lot of what kind of what
we were doing
but then we were like oh that looks
really painful uh and none of us are um
skilled when it comes to anything like
that i think it's the other way around i
think the jackass guys had no skill and
you guys would like had legitimate
communities but you guys had like stunt
stunt abilities where you're like oh i
could do that and i could twist my body
in a way that it'll hurt but i won't die
probably
yeah um everything would chatter on my
body immediately so we were like i guess
we have to write
[ __ ] so then we wrote sketches and then
ended up creating uh workaholics
based on something that we did uh on
youtube
like we did a web series and then comedy
central saw that and reached out to us
and was like
do you guys want to do a tv show and we
actually didn't we
because it was uh they like sent us a
message through youtube like
like their email type thing and
we didn't know that that existed so we
never looked at it
and uh comedy central thought we were
[ __ ] big time in them
they were like when we finally got to it
it was like three months later or
whatever
and we're like oh yeah we'll come in for
a meeting or whatever and then after we
sold the show they were like
oh we thought you guys were the coolest
[ __ ] alive
nice didn't call us back for months we
thought you were like big time than us
and we're like
yeah that's what happened yeah did
happen i remember the first time i saw
you guys
was when i showed up at the charlie
sheen roast
yeah and i got my nose broken that night
and you guys had this whole set up on
the red carpet
and they were kind of cycling interviews
through
yeah we they like you know they just
didn't know what to do with us so they
were like ah it's the new show so you
guys host a red carpet and we've never
hosted
anything before so as we were just up
there just [ __ ]
you know just being like are you gonna
give it to him hard are you gonna roast
him good
you're like yeah i guess so you're
really bad at this yeah
but it was fun man so workaholics
is like the big break and what's the
production company
making it is it you guys it was us
yeah we formed our own production badass
dude yeah and then our management
company as well they have a production
company so they had a little more
infrastructure
and then and then we just really did
everything we didn't know what the [ __ ]
we were doing so it was like a lot of
learning
as we were going because we were pretty
young we were like 25 years old when we
got the show
and we weren't like tv writers we didn't
know we just came from youtube and i was
doing a lot of stand up and that kind of
thing so we didn't know how to write for
tv durs had like written a few spec
scripts because he
you know wanted to be a writer and but
the rest of us had
no knowledge so we were literally like
running
a writer's room we hired uh someone that
we thought was really funny uh
kevin eden and he was our show runner
and he kind of helped us but literally
we would
uh uh we would like go home
and read books on how to write for
television
and then come back the next morning and
be like you know what i think
i think we should uh put a put a button
on that scene
uh going into the act break and
everyone's like yeah that's how tv works
that's what you do
so they come back and you're like that's
right so is that is that high praise for
books about how to write tv shows yeah
just that's all you have to do you just
have to read a book
yeah i love it man and so dad dude
productive that's been like a tough
nut to crack like to to get a network or
a platform to trust you enough to be the
production company
it sounds like uh like the management
company kind of helped out a little bit
and kind of
yeah that was the training wheels and
then often off you go and now you're
just bonified do everything yourself
how about the netflix movie game over
man
like what was the production company
you're you're starting the vehicle
uh dude thank you for putting me in
there
no problem man i was pumped that you
guys wanted to do it it was so fun
uh we uh we produced that as well as
uh seth rogen and evan goldberg's uh
company point grey
and and also scott rudin uh
scott rudin's company yeah and so it was
a lot of
like that was awesome because it was
netflix wasn't because they gave us like
a real budget to shoot that movie
right and so like they weren't just
gonna give us 25 million dollars
and go hey good luck uh so
luckily we had um scott
yeah just to sort of feel like give it
to him
[Laughter]
that journey behind the camera man it
can be a long road huh
seth rogen pulled it off yeah yeah i was
there the night of the premiere right i
went with you and then uh
yeah that was when you showed your hog
on on
i can't wait to talk about that um
let me let me know the little section
yeah yeah we have a hole i mean
that's the only thing
[Laughter]
the the 25 million assuming that's what
it was that they gave you to make game
over man was yeah i think it was maybe
23 million something i can't remember
exactly
well spent i mean very well spent
because for
i can kind of tell what like like when i
do something if i have a little part in
something or if i'm on a podcast like
sort of how much feedback i get
and it was absolutely overwhelming you
know i'm not just
blowing smoke up your eyes it was
absolutely overwhelming
all day every day when that movie came
out dude i saw you oh man you got killed
oh do you tell you in that movie
so i knew that you guys got eyeballs on
that man
yeah i feel i feel like our our fan base
is uh there's a lot of crossover there
i feel like yeah uh and yeah it was
awesome man
i mean and netflix is so cool because
it's it's just so easy for people
it's so easy for people to watch like
the barrier everybody has netflix like
everybody has netflix right like more
people have netflix than just have cable
uh and so uh i get like
it's an r-rated movie like i slice a
guy's face off with a meat slicer
i uh my dicks out for like three minutes
you can kind of see my butthole uh it's
it's hard it's a hard r
i get i get like uh uh
like little kids i mean i haven't lately
because of
covet times but i get like children like
12 year old kids being like
hey man gay i just want to let you know
game over man's my favorite movie
uh i watch it like with my buddies like
every night and i'm like
what dude do you watch that movie every
night
jesus christ did you did you let your
mom know that you're gonna be fully nude
or did you just wait for her to watch it
you know i can really relate to having
my family
see my wiener on a screen so yeah that's
just a great question scott
and i want to tell you that i had a
really weird experience today down
at our new warehouse where we ship out
all the stuff from my store now right of
course it's a fulfillment center
now i'm in the bathroom at the warehouse
and i'm like oh no
i need to poo and i don't have a squatty
potty
what this is this is awful so the only
thing i could do
is take the trash can and lay it on its
side
with all stuff falling out on it so that
i can prop up my legs
and poop in a healthy manner i made a
mental note
when i go home tonight i'm grabbing an
extra squatty potty
to bring to the warehouse see you just
slide it right in it goes up against the
toilet
you know it's out of the way and then
pull it out
get your feet on there and now you're in
a position to take a
full sloppy dump okay
and this is how the human body was
designed
right if you don't poo like this you're
increasing your risk for colon cancer
okay you're gonna walk away without
having a full evacuation and i want
better for you
so do this go to squattypotty.com
stevo get yourself 20
off your squatty potty you're gonna
notice it when you take a dump you're
gonna be like wow
i really completely pooped
it's a good feeling so one more time for
20 off your order go to squattypotty.com
stevo now let's talk about telling mom
about our dick
i did yeah i told her i mean the thing
is is when i
shot the scene uh when i shot when i
shot this
just to give some um reference
for people that maybe haven't seen it
what are you doing go watch it
but uh it's a terrorists have taken over
the hotel we work at
we're trying to hide in a a room
and uh they're coming down the hall with
machine guns
i take my belt off and i go i got just
the plan and you're like what is he is
he gonna attack the guy with the belt
the the they come in the hotel room and
then they open up the hotel room door
and i've auto erotic affixiated myself
and and i'm
hanging in the closet as if i'm dead
holding my dick in my hands
and so that's the seed and then uh
i we i we end up fighting these guys
uh and my dick is out the entire time so
but for the premiere i told my mom
that i my dick is gonna be out in the
movie and she's like oh it's not that i
haven't seen before you know
she's just a sweet midwestern woman and
and uh
while she i invited my parents to the
premiere you know it was a big deal for
me
and i invite them to the premiere and
my uh when my that scene comes and my
dick is out and i'm
flapping around everywhere uh my mom
reaches over to me and grabs my hand and
goes i'm so proud of you
which is the sweetest thing i mean oh my
god
thank god thank god she's like that not
just like you're you're a disappointment
yeah you're out of the family that was
uh
holding your hand at this my family
plenty
um sir how long have you been married
now and congratulations
by the way i'm not i'm not yet copen
kind of uh uh
so you just got engaged uh marathon
engagement like me
yeah how long have you been engaged for
well it's been a year now
in october what about you steve i've
been
creeping up on three years
hey just bask in the glow man
your whole life to be married right
exactly
uh yeah were you with were you with your
fiance
at the time that you shot game over man
yeah
and how did she feel about the schlong
age
she i mean she knew what she was getting
into
when she started you know she'd seen
workaholics she knows
she's she's familiar and and i also i
wrote the movie me and the guys wrote
the movie so she knew she read this
script and she was like jesus christ and
your dick is going to be
in like seven pages of your dick
yeah and i'm like well we'll cut around
it won't just be my dick the whole time
and then in the edit bay uh kyle's just
like dude
i tried to make it so it's not your dick
the whole time but
it's really funny if your dick is just
out the whole time and i'm like well
all right and what's funny when we shot
that scene like
uh the the crew guys were so
uncomfortable
at the beginning of the day because it
was a whole big fight scene
so it took like seven hours to shoot so
they're
wildly uncomfortable these are like
grizzled
seasoned you know like that or like your
dad's age just like working
a camera or a boom up and like you know
rips and [ __ ]
and by the end of the day couldn't care
less that my dick is out there like
they're actually like coming up with
better shots they're like it'd be funny
to like zoom in like down low i think
the dick will look funny
uh coming at like from this like a hero
shot
up to the dick and i'm like all right i
guess we're adding shots now
we're adding dick shots my sexy uh guy
up here
paul briskey with the sexy voice is also
my editor
and he has spent a lot of time staring
at my dick oh my god
that's true lucky lucky man i've seen
yeah
i've seen steve jack off to completion
from 12 angles
every frame yeah i had to throw together
your vasectomy bit in the beginning and
i was just like
four hours of staring at them cut your
balls open yeah and uh
yeah yeah yeah i i i had a big stunt i
was so excited about
called skyjacking where i was jacking
off i'm butt naked
in an airplane got a guy strapped to my
back and i'm
whacking it for the [ __ ] fences and i
fall out of the airplane
simultaneously blowing a load jesus
christ
yeah that's why we had 12 angles
because it was awesome world
needed it uh so you were able to i mean
that's impressive
it was a logistical nightmare yeah i
brought a dvd player with me
okay so you got yourself there
by like watching porno or whatever
correct yeah now here's the [ __ ] butt
kicker
like right before we take off they say
hey dude like this needs to happen
within a very tight window of two
minutes
because if you fall out of the airplane
at any other time we're going to miss
the drop zone
okay so i'm gonna have to kind of
[ __ ] thread the needle with this one
yeah yeah so you really you you queued
up the perfect
perfect [ __ ] scene i told them
i thought about it for a second and i
said i said okay
give me a one minutes notice give me one
minute's notice before the two minutes
starts yeah yeah
my girl at one point i remember my girl
i got
saying she [ __ ] caught me just off
guard she says you know
if it really bothers me the way that
they
that you get naked all the time you know
like with you with your dick you know i
don't like that she's like
she's like we're in an intimate
relationship and you know
i kind of feel like that's my dick i
don't like you showing it to everybody
sure yeah you know and you're like baby
it's the world's dick at this point this
is
a little bit in a better position i said
babe
whatever i do it's a lot funnier if i
got my dick out and that was
it yeah i couldn't argue with that is it
true you can't argue with that
spiritual axiom yeah an immutable law of
nature
[Laughter]
so uh i want to go back um one more
thing on the day
i'm so excited now to announce that i'm
selling at my website
autographed dick pics thank you very
much
yeah that's when you got to hit him with
the horn
let's get that cheers because i had this
one bit where i'm like you know what
women can just paint their boobs and
walk around like it's no big deal so why
can't i paint my dick
and do whatever i want it's a [ __ ]
dick pic dude where can they get those
you get them at stevo.com
in our brand new naughty store which you
have to be 18 years old to enter
yeah i'm a cyclist now too i saw uh so i
i i just got a bike i'm a fitness
influencer
i'm out there i'm letting the people
know i uh yeah
i bought a like a road bike at the
beginning nice uh
you know coveted times and i'm like i'm
gonna need to
do something during this time uh and
yeah i've just been riding
i'm not losing any weight i don't know
what it is i think i'm like dangerous
too
especially i'm also like filming myself
i'm like
you know i'm like i'm just i've crashed
multiple times my worst crash ever like
two weeks ago i'm still not okay
and i only crashed because i was filming
myself
i was like i was like this footage is
gonna be dope i'm gonna go so
[ __ ] fast and [ __ ] the footage of
me crashing
admittedly probably pretty good footy
it's it's all right it's it's
pretty good yeah it's really good like
i'm crumpled on the ground doing that
that uh really really tough to listen to
growing
[Music]
where you're like this could this could
be the end right yeah
i might have punctured something on that
one thank god i was
uh i didn't it wasn't a car because when
i got into cycling and i really got into
it so i'm always going into all the bike
shops oh let me get this out what's
going on you know
let's tune this up and it just seemed to
come up in conversation
in every bike shop that everyone i spoke
to
had a horrible little tussle with a car
which round them up in the hospital like
it's a [ __ ] dangerous activity
it is well i i i got a a little place
in orange county by the beach so i'm
like right on the beach so i'm like just
i just like
cruise the boardwalk and like on the
weekends
on the weekdays when there's nobody here
uh
it's [ __ ] great on the weekends it's
a nightmare because it's filled with
people but
uh yeah so clever but for the most part
i did get hit by a car
stayed on the bike wow didn't fall
this it clipped me uh like it was just
driving along
and then i guess it decided it was gonna
turn in this driveway and just like
turned right into me and i skid and i'm
going sideways
and i go and just straighten up and then
just kept
kept riding i felt like a [ __ ]
superhero i'm like
lance armstrong doesn't have [ __ ] on me
i just [ __ ] escaped death
yeah dude [ __ ] right on man have you
always lived i mean i know you came from
ohio but uh you went to orange coast
college right
uh omaha not ohio would i say
oh sorry ohio yeah it's okay and uh
people like
if it's it's just the oh if you're not
from omaha no one
it's a flyover state nobody yeah people
just don't even know it and they're like
ohio orlando i don't know where the [ __ ]
ever you live oklahoma it doesn't matter
uh but yeah i moved out here when i
i went to orange coast college in costa
mesa which is just
right up the street from me now uh i
took an emt class there
that's where i got oh yeah yeah yeah go
pirates yeah
oh yeah and uh it's
it's like a community college it's you
know it was it was so fun
and uh i i basically moved to orange
county because my parents like thought
i would just get [ __ ] gang-raped if i
moved right to la they were like
they're like you're too cute uh
to just move right down like yeah you
couldn't argue with it
uh because that booty was popping at 18.
and uh baseball but yeah i had that
baseball
but donk and yeah so they were just like
well i actually saw the movie orange
county this is the reason i moved to
orange county i saw the movie orange
county it came out when i was like 17
years old or something with colin hanks
and um jack black and
the whole premise of the [ __ ] movie
is colin hanks is like
he he wants to get out of here and he
doesn't want to go to the community
college
down the street uh where it's just
nothing but
stoners and and dumb hot chicks and
all uh every all everybody does every
day is just smoke weed and go to the
beach and
he needs to get out of there and i'm
like i need to get there
i'm like that's where i want to go to
school
yeah and so my parents were like okay
it's not you're not living right in
hollywood you can go there and then i
went there and then two years later
i got i had like zero transferable
credits i think i had six
i took two years of school with six
transferable credits
and uh all i took was like improv
classes and creative writing and you
know screenwriting
and uh so i couldn't go to an actual
four-year college
after the two years and so i was like
i'm just gonna
give comedy a try and my parents at that
time were like all right
whatever yeah so when did you start
doing stand-up was that when you were at
school
yeah i started uh when i was like
i really started in like earnest when i
was about 19 or 20.
and that's when i like really uh uh
would would go for it and would do open
mics all the time and
[Music]
kind of took it more serious um and i
got a job working
at the hollywood improv which was like
to me
like the greatest gig i i consider that
my first break
in hollywood because i they weren't
hiring i went every [ __ ] day
and was like hey are you guys hiring yet
and they're like we're not hiring
and finally they're just like jesus
you're you've beaten us down
you can answer phones during the day and
i got to know
everybody i got to know the bookers
everyone knew me
i went i said hollywood improv adam
devine speaking like i let them know
that i'm adam devine
i like everybody even just people are
just trying to buy tickets like oh i
don't care at all who you are uh
two tickets for daniel foster or
whatever um but it's cool and i got to
see
like what's great about working the
hollywood improv it's like one of the
best comedy clubs in the
world so you see every great comedian
come through there
it's not like you're working at the the
chuckle hut in cincinnati or some [ __ ]
you're like
it is the like premier comedy club that
in the comedy store
and so i got to see like chris rock and
all the all
just the [ __ ] greats and yeah and i
think it helped me
um be less shitty uh out the gate
dude there needs to be a comedy club
called the chuckle hut i was just
wondering if that was true or not
i bet there is like there are so many
bad
comedy clubs
[ __ ] just get that website
we'll share it with you dude i'll go and
go daddy and get the website
uh for sure there's a i mean there's
there's like
you know there's bananas there's zany's
there's the funny bones
i hope uh like i think the improvs are
going to be okay because there's
you know they're a huge chain uh but i'm
like kind of worried for some of these
smaller
comments with with kovid i
you know it just sucks since i'm such a
fan of comedy clubs i think they're
right i just think they're the best and
i remember like when i was a kid
my parents when they would go to a
comedy club
and then they'd come home and they're
just drunk
and they're like oh man that was the
best
and i remember being like excited to
like hear stories about like what the
comedy
what the comic would say or like what
happened did they pick on anyone was
there a heckler like
i was just stoked on that whole uh
you know the whole thing for sure man i
love that too and
yeah i worry about clubs too like our
guy
dan and peoria the jukebox oh yeah
like i wonder what's going on with him
well yeah what about like during uh the
pandemic have you
been able to shoot any movies if you're
like uh like what like what's going on
no i haven't no i just i really i i
i did i'm doing the podcast with the
workaholics guys this is important
uh is the name of the podcast and it's
also
really important uh that we have a
podcast
four more guys with a podcast it's
important
and uh so that's been like i'm like
thank god we did that because we've been
talking about it for a couple years now
and it's like
it's like a good way to like keep in
touch and we all like
we used to all live together for like
years for like
seven eight years we lived together and
like when you were all just
communicating it's easy to like have the
creative juices
flowing and that's why like our output
was so great during that time
like we we hundreds of videos and then
we and then into workaholics and we were
seeing each other every day
and we did you know 80 something
episodes and then work and then
game over man and writing other [ __ ] but
then we kind of for the last couple
years
haven't seen each other as much and i
was like [ __ ] and so we got
the podcast and luckily we're doing that
but no i haven't really shot
anything during this this time it was i
i have like a lot of stuff that
he was about to go and then because of
covid it just
was put on put on the back burner i'm
i'm doing uh
i was in south carolina about to shoot
the second season of the righteous
gemstones
um yeah thanks
um yeah i'm like i i love it and it's
like the cast is incredible
and uh danny mcbride and
edie patterson who plays my sister is
hilarious uh
john goodman walton goggins and
um danny we were about to start yeah
danny's the best he's the
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's also just like the
coolest nicest guy
you know it's it's it's cool when you
meet someone and you're like
i hope they're cool you know it'd be a
bummer if you met someone and they're
and they're like ah but danny's like
exceeded my expectations
because he plays like kind of like like
kind of
[ __ ] a little bit like you know
what i mean and so you're like i hope
he's just not a [ __ ] [ __ ]
like his characters but he isn't he's
like the nicest guy and he's so [ __ ]
cool
so we're about to start shooting that i
literally was like day one of shooting
and there and then the news is like uh
you know all of a sudden it's a global
pandemic and we're like that's what
we're calling it we're gonna
we're going with global pandemic that
seems pretty serious
and then they're like yeah you know i
think uh
you guys it looks like
you should probably go home we'll
probably be back in like three weeks as
our guest and then we'll fire everything
back
up and then once we get this under
control and then and then
start back up and then you know that was
in
uh february so right [ __ ]
that's when like three weeks sounded
like a long time to like shoot yeah
three weeks oh my god now we're about to
go house for three weeks
i know dude it's nuts well down in
orange county they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ]
they do not care it's it's actually like
i mean a little bit it's a little bit
awesome because you're like
it seems kind of normal but at the same
time you're like oh this is
this is just a hot bed like they don't
yeah
they don't care at all i went on a date
yesterday
and uh we went to this restaurant and
nobody had their mask on everybody even
walking around the town i was just like
freaking out we were down at carlsbad
it's down in san clemente okay and it
was just like uh
just walking around town nobody gives a
[ __ ]
and the server came and she had a face
shield on
and the face shield was at like a
straight angle so like
even it was just channeling everything
everything was just dropping
and i went on a date with a nurse and i
was like hey look i'm not trying to
freak out you know but like this is kind
of gnarly she's like
oh this whole room is [ __ ] because of
this girl right here and she brought out
the lattes
and like it was just going right down
into the lattes like oliver spit you
know
how did you meet the nurse a dating
website
like a hinge i went on hinge when i was
down there
yeah how much time are you spending with
me i already deleted it
it's just too much so so you're in this
like
this like oh i deleted oh no okay i'll
try it again like no no no
because i was working down there a lot i
was like man i'm just working so hard
and then uh
i needed a little release
i got on a dating app and then it just
so you swear off the dating app and then
you relapse
yeah how many times have you deleted it
in my life
yeah and then put it back like nine
it's just insanity you know i actually i
because i've been dating my girl for so
long that i like
missed the whole dating app
movement that that has happened and it's
actually
like it looks [ __ ] awesome dude
i can't argue there man i i see like uh
they see scott's apologetic
and and like it's sort of you know not
not all on because he thinks it's a bad
thing so he'll delete it and then put it
back on
but we have like other buddies that are
just all about the swipe
and they're just swiping and they're
just yeah i asked my buddy i was like
dude
i was like uh how many dating apps are
you on he's like
all of them dude and then we got we got
a couple guys that are
really mowing them down one in
particular
yeah really mowing down like pretty hot
chicks
hey let me ask you how long were you
dating your fiance until you started
farting in front of her
i'm absolutely gonna let adam answer
that question
but first i'm gonna tell you that i
started confidently
farting in front of lux about a year
into our relationship
and she just started ripping them about
six months ago
so i've told you that now let me tell
you
that when i was down at the warehouse in
san diego this is where we ship all of
our stuff it's a fulfillment center a
shipping house it's called
tight box packing and scott says dude
i'm thinking about getting a
pad down here in san diego i said what
are you talking about dude
we got this upstairs space and
we have a [ __ ] bed sponsor bro let's
talk to the helix people and say yo man
we
we need another bed it'll be rad because
i
love helix bed so much and they ship it
to you
where it's like all in this box
when you open up the box and it's it
like becomes this
dense like awesome comfortable mattress
and it is precisely exactly the one
that's perfect for you
because they just have you go on their
website and you take a two minute quiz
you plug in the info and they spit out
exactly what's the perfect mattress for
you
and then man you get it's the best thing
i love my helix
i'm going to beg the company for another
one and
if you want to take this easy two minute
quiz and go to
helix sleep.com
stevo you will get up to 200 off of
any mattress of your choosing if you get
one two
free pillows you know do it man
get two free pillows and up to 200 off
of any mattress you want
at helix sleep.com stevo
all right now let's talk about farting
we covered that the other day
i i'm not like a huge
farter fart like i don't it just doesn't
happen that often like like some some
people just
it's they're just very flatulent people
i'm not that flatulent of a guy
so i mean i have for sure uh
i it actually what's great about chloe
is she can't smell that well
like truly i've like i've i've farted
and
and then and then she walks in the room
and i'm like you know
like early on in the relationship i try
to like dissipate the fart
with my kids spinning around yeah and
she's like what are you doing i'm like
nothing what what's up
and then she's like just sat sat down
and like started to eat eggs or so like
it was just like
i had a meal it smells good what is it
in the room that i just like
bombed and i was like oh she's gonna
she's gonna smell this i had no
recollect didn't know it at all and i'm
like
i think i love you
i was like this is it yeah she's the one
that's how you knew she was the one yeah
do you plan on having a family yeah yeah
i think so
uh you know yeah i i
i want to get married i just want to get
married before
i had the the kids i don't know it's
kind of old school
uh but i'm like that that was just
because we were gonna get married we had
a whole day
planned and everything and then the
venue
cancelled all events for all of 2021
oh next year but we had a date for like
september of next year and then they're
like
you know what [ __ ] it and
yeah you don't want all of our money all
right so now i'm like i don't know yeah
we might just start churning kids out
now
who knows it seems that like i heard
divorce rates like going people
like filing for divorce because during
the pandemic everybody's
forced to to you know deal with their
shots
yeah the pandemic really puts your
relationship
to the test and i'm stoked that my girl
and i
haven't gotten burned out on each other
we just get along great
yeah we do we do too like there's i
think
i don't get bothered by things like i
like i don't let things like stack up on
me like if something's bothering you
i'll just
be like bothering me i'll just let you
know right away
uh but like i think things stack up
on on her a little bit because uh
i didn't know that i breathe heavy
but that's like something that like
she's just like jesus christ
you're breathing so heavy i'm like i'm
just what
i'm just breathing and you know it's
like the little things that she's like
are you you really you're gonna chew you
you are chewing with your mouth
open right now and i'm like i don't even
know i'm doing that i'm sorry
i don't know but for the most part yeah
it's been it's been pretty
yeah it's like it would suck it would
suck if like there was a few like
cracks in the armor and then and then
really
you have to be with that person all the
time and then all of a sudden it's just
but also why get divorced now
it would be a horrible time to be right
going through a divorce
because you i mean besides this maniac
over
here you can't it's like dating right
now it's probably
pretty difficult right yeah it's i mean
i i'm scott what
because he takes the pandemic very
[ __ ] seriously
and like so here like every date like
oh my god i gotta get get a copy test
this last girl i went on a date with
like she already had it
the hypochondriac [ __ ] sex addict
yeah there's a dilemma here you know
it's like i uh i won't i won't have sex
all all
quarantined and then all of a sudden i'm
like you know i'm gonna start having sex
again and i'm like [ __ ] i can't do that
anymore
and then i'll just go like another six
months without even having sex
a tortured individual that's rough i'm
sorry you have to do that man
it's okay i don't mind sometimes do you
have any pets adam
no i don't i uh i wish i would have
gotten
i want to get a dog but i mean uh
well that's yours stevo i can't have
your dog right you just look down at his
dog i'm like
yeah that's yours i i wanna i wanna get
a dog but i you know how it is is i'm
always traveling
and i uh like when i go to
charleston uh i rent a house there and
they're like
it's very hard to find a house that
they'll rent and then also
let you bring your dog charleston south
carolina
yeah how are you gonna be there dude
we're
that we have to do so many safety
protocols we're shooting 10 episodes
that should take for three four months
tops
tops six months because of all the
safety protocols
you can you can only shoot like
something like eight hours a day
and then they gotta spend two hours
cleaning everything like at the end yeah
every day and uh and then that like
every
couple every like two weeks they have to
take a week off
yeah for sterilization pro i have no
idea
exactly what why the [ __ ] it's gonna
take so long but i'm like
okay so i'm like uh i'm i'm gonna
you know rent this house for for six
months but i wish i would have gotten a
dog at the beginning of quarantine
because it would have been a good
just a little quarantined buddy you know
yeah dude
it's the best man it is you got
is that the dog that you got in peru
right
yeah thank you for knowing that yeah i
did it
i weirdly didn't know that she's she's a
a bona fide [ __ ] star
man i i love this [ __ ] dog so much
she loves the podcast too when we're
setting up she like i think it's because
she gets treats when she lays there but
she
just loves it she jumps in the van first
yeah oh dude she's
she's ready to work yeah
i mean i had i had something i [ __ ]
zac efron oh yeah
what's up with zac efron
we're all dying to know dude we all got
it yeah
[Music]
yeah he's like well it's weird because
he's like a
a pretty i mean he's a really nice dude
great guy but like he yes he is like a
super hot
super hot dude i for whatever reason
that i keep getting cast
like opposite like honky dudes like
hunky dudes and then i'm like the
regular guy schlub that i think
america can relate to and they're like
yeah i'm kind of like him and then
there's always that
[ __ ] hunk over there and um
and i because i worked with liam
hemsworth in a movie
isn't it romantic and also he's the same
thing where it's just like you're just
like jesus christ
like you want you like you won't see him
for a while and then you'll he'll be
like
you're at craft services or whatever and
then all of a sudden zach or liam is
like right next to you and you're like
jesus
god damn you're sexy you know yeah
hotter off camera than they are on
camera
but specifically yeah the camera can't
capture all that beauty but
uh specifically i saw like
grown women like 50 year old women like
melt in front of him like act like
little girls
like oh and like objectify him in a way
that i've never seen a man
objectify well i take that back there
because
i've been i've been to strip clubs but
um but
uh no like just like truly just like
melt in front of him i'm like oh this is
weird dude and he's like yeah it's so
weird like he's like
i don't even like to if i see like a
pack of like 50 year old women i try to
steer clear because they
they will just lose their minds and i'm
like yeah that's that is a weird
i don't have that problem at all
poor guy me it's like 20 30 year old
dudes i'm like [ __ ] i gotta
yeah yeah some kids with a skateboard
you're like let's get out of here like
denny's like two in the morning it's
like [ __ ] dude okay going that way and
you know
that guy friends like dude there's like
hot milk sort of trying to [ __ ]
yeah way too much [ __ ] over there
yeah he's like oh god i can't even walk
past that
christ that's it were you uh in hawaii
with zach
when he [ __ ] rode the tiger shark
yeah dude we were together uh
ocean ramsay ocean ramsey that's right
he goes
you know it's early on in shooting the
movie and zach is like
yo dude uh tomorrow i gotta set up you
want to go uh shark diving
and i'm like no i'm trying to be
i'm i'm trying to like fit in you know
it's like my first
star roll in the movie so i'm like well
if he's doing it i guess i should do it
and i went and dude that was like the
[ __ ] scariest thing
first of all didn't know i got seasick
wildly seasick
and so we get out there and she's like
it'll actually be better once you're in
the water
and uh and i go oh okay and i get in the
water
and they she's like if any of the sharks
are being aggressive i'll like
tell you this shark and and she's like
if they pop their gills out and if they
come up next to you and hip
check you that's they're like sizing you
up
and i'm like oh okay
sure enough there's like 17 sharks in
the water
they're they're [ __ ] everywhere your
head's on a swivel and the shark comes
right up next to me
it's like popping its gills and just
like it comes out of nowhere
from the deep blue and just hip checks
my ass
by a [ __ ] shark and i'm like oh what
the [ __ ]
and then she's like come on come up when
i go up and she's like
that shark is being weirdly very
aggressive to you i'd recommend
uh getting back on the boat for a while
and just kind of letting letting him
chill out i'm like
good call and i get on the the boat
puking
zach's zack's in the water he's having a
great time
they're all female sharks like they're
all girls
uh and uh i get back on the boat now i'm
seasick
i'm puking i'm puking off that i'm
chumming the water with
my own vomit and then she's like what
are you doing you're trimming the water
and i'm like
i'm seasick and she goes i'm gonna need
you to get back in the water i'm like
with that mean shark and she's like
and all this i'm back in the water the
shark is kind of leaving me alone i'm
like oh
what the [ __ ] and uh all of a sudden the
sharks
disappear behind me disappear in front
of me i see them all just like
swim off into the darkness and i'm like
well that's a weird sign
and she's like come up we we come up
ocean ramsay
meezak ocean uh when we we go up and
and she's like hey there must be an apex
predator
in the water or like more than the
sharks
and they're like yeah it's uh either a
great white which i doubt
i think it's probably a tiger shark sure
enough this huge
the thing was like 13 feet long it was
[ __ ]
massive tiger shark and they're like
let's she goes
just it's more interested in the boat
than us
it's it's it's been circling us for a
while uh
let's just stay close to the boat and uh
you know and
let it chill and i'm like i'm gonna stay
on the ladder that's where i'm staying
and uh and the shark is swimming around
zach swims over to it grabs it by its
fin and rides it as if it's a
[ __ ] uh like a little little kid
ride that you put a quarter in at like
outside of a kmart or some [ __ ]
and he rides it the shark does nothing
he comes up and we're all like holy [ __ ]
that's insane
oh my god and she's like yeah definitely
don't do that again that is insane
and we go back down he rides it again
this time the shark like gives him like
a little like shoulder shimmy
uh and just like sort of wiggle them off
we come back up and we're like oh my god
ocean's like that's crazy
definitely don't do that again oh holy
[ __ ] that's wild
zack does it a third time a third time
grabs it now the shark's just like get
the [ __ ] off me dude
why don't you keep touching me and the
shark like
through like bunk and bronco style threw
him off
and zach like goes flying in the water
and then comes up and ocean's like
that's great everybody on the boat right
now
that's insane we're done and yeah but
then
you know but in hindsight zach didn't
get bit
nothing bad happened he looks cool as
[ __ ] in the story
uh he got to go on all the talk shows we
he has a video
so we have all this really cool footage
of him like swimming up to the shark
grabbing it by its fin looking all cool
meanwhile i'm like in the background
like
yeah just puking on myself underwater
swimming swimming backwards like i look
like such a [ __ ]
meanwhile zack's like looking all cool
swimming towards it and i'm like
aggressively doggy paddling away but
that whole story like it hit me so hard
because
going back to you know when jackass was
a little tv show on mtv i mean like 20
[ __ ] years ago
and we go out with manny the shark guy
and he's
and that was the deal we're gonna go
ride a shark we're gonna
we thought we were gonna do that manny
[ __ ]
grabs the fan he's riding the shark all
over like we realized
this is not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen at all and like
kind of over the years just gave up on
that you know just
gave up on on that dream and then all
the fun
all the [ __ ] sudden i see zac efron
do it and i'm like
i can't give up on that i can't give up
dude [ __ ] zac efron can do that dude
then
then i'm not gonna [ __ ] throw in the
towel dude and so we reached out to
ocean ramsay ourselves
oh really trying to [ __ ] make it
happen right yeah
you reached out and she was like okay
well it could happen on you know
monday or tuesday and you're like i'll
book every trip that week
right right now she was like if she she
says
it's better if if we book two sessions
in one
so we go for a morning dive and like uh
you know the afternoon dive and i was
like i'll do
two [ __ ] sessions every [ __ ] day
for
like two weeks i don't care like let's
get it done
yeah i forget why we didn't but well
that's uh
oahu or that's uh what island is that
north shore of oahu mm-hmm i'm telling
you february dude
let's go write a shark yeah do it stevo
i'm rooting
for you my man uh and what's funny is i
was like
after that everyone's like oh
was that terrifying i'm like yeah for
sure it was uh
and i was like you know what i did that
i'm never gonna do it again now i've
been shark diving like
four other times i've done shark week on
discovery channel twice now
uh i i did it for my own show bad ideas
that i did on quibby
uh and i'm now i'm like a shark guy so
i'll come with you i'll write a sharpie
dude tell us about quibby man when did
that go down
uh when did my show uh dissolve the
entire company
when did my my show ruined the billion
dollar company
uh it was awesome it they right before
the pandemic
started uh they i did
eight episodes and i did all kinds of
cool [ __ ] i like i swam
with a meat diaper in the uh
up in the amazon river trying to get
piranhas to attack me
um dude i well i'm
i'm very truthful when i say that uh
specifically wild boys that that show
inspired me i'm like thank you man yeah
so and she
knew that piranhas would want no [ __ ]
part in messing with you because you're
not dead
dude i yeah i didn't know that i didn't
know that
and then when you saw it i have all this
like meat on my dick
and thinking like oh this is gonna be
insane like and
and it you know and uh couldn't get
couldn't get a piranha to we saw
products they're like there's a piranha
and it's just me like tea bag in the
water uh
and then and then it wasn't until later
that um someone's like well you know
you're not supposed to pee in the amazon
river because they
because they have their own parasites
that go up your dick hole and they'll
go in your bloodstream yeah and i'm like
oh
well i wish someone would have told me
that at the beginning of the [ __ ]
right yeah and mostly the bad idea
essentially the show is me and a
celebrity friend travel around
the world do an inherently dumb
crazy silly bad ideas and
it was super fun and i i hope to to do
it again
uh but then quibby like fully dissolved
like oh [ __ ] yeah the quivi uh yeah
quibby's like done
they're like they're done and so they
like
closed up shop admittedly they launched
at the worst time
that a time when you're like especially
they launched like at the beginning of
the pandemic
when everybody's at home everyone's like
well i'm going to watch
my big ass tv and i'm going to watch an
hour long i'm going to re-watch the
sopranos or whatever
people did tiger king tiger king for
sure yeah
i did i did everything i watched so much
goddamn tv i watched tiger king
i watched uh i re-watched the sopranos
i watched entourage i watched
uh i like was deep in the cut i'm i'm
re-watching breaking bad right now
i watched mad men i'm like i've been
putting in work
people ask what i did in the pandemic
they're like did you write any movies
did you do anything
have you been working on your stand-up
no none of it
but i tell you what don draper did in
oh man that's so great do you do and do
you enjoy
uh sports like i'm a big ufc fan
i can't get enough but i watch every
fight i you know i
every time i watch ufc i [ __ ] love it
and i'm like why don't i watch
this all the time and then i just don't
it's the same with boxing every time i
i watch boxing and i'm like what an
awesome
sport this is uh and then and then i
just never
ever watch it but i i watch uh i do like
i i'm a big basketball fan so i was glad
when they came back and and
did the bubble i was like oh thank god
and also like at that point
i was just like binge watching the news
dude you know
yeah my boy lester yeah i'm a situation
room guy myself
my boy oh blitzer yeah that guy
that guy that guy hit it [ __ ]
for sure wolf hold me wolf
the first time i i didn't ever watch the
news and i was doing
um i i was doing classes at the second
city in la
and which is an improv school for people
that don't know and
uh i was taking classes and they are
really big into politics they're like
you should know
stuff because it's it's good to lampoon
politics and
you know and so i'm like oh okay and
then someone like brought in a sketch it
was like
uh and he calls himself wolf blitzer and
and i'm laughing i'm like crying
laughing
because i think it's a fake name that he
made up
and i'm like that is the most hilarious
sounding name
i was like that's too and then like it's
his real name i'm like [ __ ]
there's not a human being out there
named wolf blitzer
who's a newscaster what is that
yeah it's like one of santa's reindeer
or something
yeah it didn't even occur to me that how
dope that name really is
well then like all the weather men on
the news or like dallas reigns or like
they're like there's different [ __ ]
are those fake or those real or is it
like destiny for those guys to
do what they do yeah i feel like if your
name is dallas reigns you
have to be a weatherman though in omaha
when i was growing up the
the uh weatherman was named jim flowers
yeah and he always had like a flower
boutonniere
on on his lapel of his jacket every i
think like if you have a silly dumb name
like that you're like well there's
there's one career path for me for you
dude epic uh hey do you sell merch
do you have like a website with an
online store and [ __ ] we're
getting that right now for the podcast
but it's it is not
up and running quite yet yeah
but uh but i i i need to
yeah dude maybe we like to ask people
that
um we do we typically like to sort of
you know be invasive ask people like
what their top revenue stream is you
know
yeah but uh not just i'm particularly
interested in merch because we just
started our own fulfillment center
you know it's uh we took over the the
act of actually fulfilling each order
that comes in with our own warehouse and
everything
oh wow cool yeah that's why uh i'm able
to
distribute signed dick pics at stevo.com
but yeah dude hey man i got to say dude
i i was
surprised and honored and overjoyed that
we got to
do this with you man dude yeah i was
stoked i was stoked that you guys asked
i uh
yeah i would have i would have done it a
million years ago you know i [ __ ] i
love you dude and uh
dad i appreciate that yeah i just
appreciate i appreciate you asking me
you got me in in my biggest movie today
dude
i made a i made a silly youtube video
about
i called it my humiliating acting career
you know and as embarrassing as it is
each little random movie role was like
a step up from the last one you know and
it all culminated in this blockbuster
hit which was game over man game over
i got to star alongside your schlong
and and don't forget about shaggy shaggy
was also
uh yeah a big star i didn't get nearly
as much screen time as your schlong
yeah he was my dick got third billing so
it had to seven pages that dick
yeah yes seg after rules were uh we had
to give him a certain amount of speed
at a speaking role
well yeah dude is there anything that we
can send traffic to
your your instagram your your website uh
yeah i mean i can come come [ __ ] with me
on uh
on instagram just adam devine i uh
i recently changed i was going i had the
pseudonym
of andy bovine i remember which was a
nickname
that i got in high school uh because
adam devine just sounds like a fake name
it just sounded like too cool for with
the spazzy little
you know kid i was so like i was hanging
out with a lot of older kids when i was
like freshman sophomore and like one of
the seniors was like
yo dude your name is no longer adam
devine it's andy bovine
and i'm like hey i also like that
nickname so but then i was getting
people that i
considered like i was friends with them
but like they're hollywood friends so we
don't really see each other that often
we'd see each other at parties
and i remember like uh like i remember
some dude was like um
who i considered a buddy was like hey
andy i want to introduce you to some
someone and i'm like oh and then
like thinking oh he just kind of
misspoke and then he goes hey this is uh
andy bovine this is and i'm like
no did you go along with it no i called
him out right then i'm like you think my
name is andy beauvoir
like it's wolf blitzer
and he's like he's like yeah and i'm
like oh it's adam devine he goes i
thought adam devine was like your stage
name and your real name is andy bovine
and i'm like
and i gotta just get rid of it so it's
now at adam devine
on instagram it's like this this is
cheetos santina
hey you you meant cheetos
yeah yeah dude well right on me i've
been if i was following andy bovine for
years now
i don't even know that i noticed it it
changed man but but that works for me
too
awesome let's go swim with some sharks
soon yeah oh yeah
we're looking at uh surfing uh
been at the base of snow-covered
mountains in alaska
and then hopping on a plane over to
hawaii to ride
sharks this february jesus christ
you live such a great lifestyle well hey
man if you want to tag along and barf on
yourself dude
[Laughter]
yeah he's got terrible terrible
seasickness yeah i did the same thing in
fiji
dude the thing is is uh you don't know
you're seasick
until you're out there yakking like and
i've been on both before it just like
sometimes it hits and sometimes it
doesn't
100 of the time
and he's a real waterman too you can't
get enough of the ocean
yeah it's crazy yeah it is wild
[ __ ] hey man right on brother awesome
again truly an honor
hell yeah guys let's do this again
sometime i love you dog thank you so
much
thanks man hello thanks adam super cool
man yeah later
see you paul with your with your sexy
ass voice hey thank you brother
did i mention that i was just down in
san diego at our new fulfillment center
it's a warehouse and the business is
called tight box packing
well i'll tell you it was a rough trip
because i didn't have wendy and i also
didn't have lux
after thought
[Laughter]
i mean like [ __ ] but
it was it was a productive trip and as i
told adam devine
there are dick pics for sale at
stevo.com
if you go right now you'll find both
autographed gnarly dvds
and autographed dick pics but hurry up
because those dvds are going to
disappear man
thanks for hanging out until the end
guys i love you so much